John F Kennedy served as the 35th
President of the United States before he
was killed in 1963 while we all know
about JFK chances are that you probably
know more about the conspiracy theory
surrounding his assassination than the
actual details of his life this story
goes far deeper than just the individual
life of John F Kennedy in order to
understand the man you need to know the
family and how he was far from the only
one whose life ended in tragedy on
today's bhaiyya graphics we will discuss
the real man who was behind the
presidency the Kennedys have been called
American royalty and to the outside
world they were a symbol of the American
dream it all started when Patrick
Kennedy married Bridget Murphy who
emigrated from Ireland to the United
States in the 1800s Patrick died at an
early age leaving Bridget a widow and a
single mother she became a full-time
maid for a wealthy family in Boston
after a few years though Bridget Kennedy
managed to save her money and opened up
in general store her only son Patrick
jr. was called PJ at 14 years old he
started working in the general store
with his mother when he was in his 20s
PJ opens an Irish pub he made so much
money that he purchased a bar in an
upscale hotel as well as a local bank
PJ's son Joseph P Kennedy would be the
first to grow up enjoying the fruits of
his ancestors labor
he went to Harvard University where he
got a taste of high society
unfortunately though joseph was snubbed
by a lot of his classmates and denied
from entering several fraternities while
it's hard to imagine now there was
actually a huge stigma against Irish
Catholics back then especially among the
American elite most of the upper-class
American families were descended from
British Protestants who taught their
children that the Irish were low class
good-for-nothing drugs this stereotype
it motivated Joseph Kennedy to become a
millionaire and prove everybody wrong
Joseph Kennedy married the mayor of
Boston's daughter Rose Fitzgerald they
went on to have nine children together
the oldest son was named Joseph jr. and
even as an infant his parents would say
that he would grow up to be the
President of the United States his
second son John Fitzgerald Kennedy was
born on May the 29th 1917 but everyone
called him jack
Rose would go on to have seven more
children and they all grew up watching
their father work hard to make his first
million before the age of 35 in the
1920s Joseph Kennedy was hustling to
make as much money as he could by any
means necessary he took advantage of
prohibition by buying up the alcohol
just before the laws were scheduled to
change
he ran speakeasies with a man named Sam
Giancana who was connected to the
Chicago mob he also played the stock
market and made millions running schemes
that would now be considered rather
illegal before long Joseph Kennedy
became the richest Irish Catholic in the
United States since he was always trying
to climb the ladder for more money and
more power dress of Kennedy began to get
involved in politics President Franklin
Delano Roosevelt was impressed by
Kennedy's wits and charisma and so he
was appointed as the ambassador to Great
Britain considering that he had spent
his entire life trying to prove that
Irish men could be just as successful as
the English this was the cherry on top
of Kennedy's achievements and the only
way it could get any better was if one
of his sons became the president
[Music]
John Kennedy was an adorable baby with
big blue eyes but even during his
earliest days in life he was already
very sick by the age of three he had had
whooping cough chickenpox the measles
and scarlet fever jack was also
diagnosed with the condition called
Addison's disease indeed because of all
of this he spent a lot of his young life
living in the hospital his parents they
were told by doctors that he may not
survive to adulthood however Jack was a
very happy kid and he had a lot of love
for life friends and relatives say that
he never complained about his illnesses
and that he was always smiling
and always making jokes his siblings
made light of his condition joking that
if a mosquito bit him he would die
instantly the Kennedy children they were
out meeting members of the British
aristocracy from a young age so they
were taught traditional attic attic they
became this uniquely all-american family
who had the charm of British royalty
while most of the children were living
with their father in London both Jack
and his older brother Joe Jr attended a
private high school called Choate
Rosemary Hall in Connecticut Joe jr. was
the most popular guy in school and the
all-around golden boy he was a varsity
football player who was good-looking
outgoing charismatic and got straight
A's
Jack on the other hands was the polar
opposite of his older brother because of
his disease he grew up feeling as if
every day might be his last so he was
constantly living life to the fullest he
got C's in every subject except English
and history just like his father dragged
out some backlash from his peers for
being Irish some of the other kids
called him marker because that was the
nickname given to Irish men who would
clean up the horse manure in the stables
of English novels instead of sulking
Jack countered the bullies by embracing
the name and even proudly wore a
necklace with a gold shovel charm he
created a group on campus called the
Markus club and they dedicated their
free time to playing crazy pranks around
campus soon enough being a mocker wasn't
a derogatory term anymore
it was a badge of honor some of the most
popular boys in the school joined his
club so that they could raise hell if
YouTube had existed back then there is
no doubt that they would be filming
these pranks and putting them on the
platform in fact Kennedy was planning a
prank where they'd bring in a huge
amount of manure into the middle of the
school's dance floor and take
photographs of the students and teachers
reactions when they open the doors when
the Dean caught wind of this plan he
called in Joseph Kennedy for a
parent-teacher conference jack was
nearly kicked out of school but his
father stepped in and
for being expelled with a wink and a
smile Joseph's senior was teaching Jack
that he didn't have to play by the rules
that normal people played by the
Kennedys they were always able to pay
someone off
unfortunately Jack's recklessness it
would catch up to him when he became
seriously injured during a football game
he ruptured a disc in his back and it
took months of surgeries and time in the
hospital before he could even walk again
he never fully recovered and to be in
pain for the rest of his life after
graduating from high school Jack went to
Harvard outside of class he joins the
swimming and sailing teams and was known
for being a ladies man even though he
had a passion for English literature his
father pushed him to study political
science and law he also arranged for him
and his older brother Joe jr. to get
summer jobs in the American Embassy in
London Jack and his father they would
send letters back and forth about
politics and when World War two began he
already had plenty of insider knowledge
about what was going on in Europe for
his senior thesis Jack wrote a book
called why England slaps which basically
reiterated his father's beliefs about
how he believed Great Britain was not
prepared for World War two it became a
best-seller and it established the name
John F Kennedy as a political expert at
an early age while Jack was finishing up
his degree at Harvard his father Joseph
Kennedy senior was teeming with the very
real possibility that the United States
would join in World War two even though
he was living in London at the time
Joseph Kennedy made it very clear that
he was an isolationist which meant that
he did not want American to join the war
and in 1940 he made a comment to the
press that he believed that he could
negotiate a peace treaty with that off
Hitler because of this statement people
assumed that he was a Nazi sympathizer
and he was forced to step down as the
Ambassador Jack and his older brother
Joe jr. both wanted to join the Navy
after the United States officially
entered World War two in 1941 when Jack
went through the medical examination he
was rejected because of his past back
injury his father however paid off the
army officials and they let him pass
through Joe jr. went on to become a
pilot in Europe while Jack worked as the
commander of a torpedo ship in the South
Pacific called pt-109 his back was in
near constant pain but he always
suffered in silence swimming and sailing
every summer it paid off the jack in a
huge way because during the war pt-109
was attacked by the Japanese and it
began to sink
he spent three hour
swimming around the wreckage making sure
that he had accounted for all of the
survivors one of the men
Patrick McMahon was badly burned all
over his body and he could hardly move
Kennedy was the strongest swimmer of the
group so he had to tow Patrick McMahon
by pulling a string from his life jacket
with his teeth he led his men as they
swam three miles to a nearby island
safety and they were rescued a week
later when Jack returned home he weighed
only 120 pounds and he was in
excruciating pain he had to wear a back
brace and walk with a cane for several
months he was awarded the Navy and
Marine Corps medal for his service the
entire family celebrated its bravery by
throwing him a party
Jack's older brother Joe junior came
home for the party but he felt a deep
sense of shame because he never did
anything to prove that he was a war hero
in an attempt to be like his younger
brother Joe accepted an extremely
dangerous mission to carry sensitive
explosives in a plane bus before he
could complete the mission the plane
exploded in midair Joseph Kennedy jr.
died at just 29 years old Jack Kennedy
never wanted to be President of the
United States he was very much a free
spirit and he wasn't suited for politics
he always said that he wanted to be a
writer who sailed around the world but
now that Joe Jr was gone his father
turned to Jack to fulfill all of his
hopes and dreams even though he didn't
have very much experience in politics
his father used his money and
connections to propel JFK's career
supported by their father his siblings
pitched in by spending a lot of their
time running Jack's campaign as their
full-time job through his late twenties
and early thirties he quickly moved up
the House of Representatives and then
the Senate in 1953 Jack Kennedy married
Jacqueline Bouvier she was a young
socialite and a writer at the Washington
time Herald just like Jack she had also
been groomed by her wealthy East Coast
family to be the perfect first lady she
could speak French Italian and Spanish
fluently which aided her later on in
international diplomacy soon after
marrying Jacqueline JFK wrote his second
book called profiles of courage which
won him a Pulitzer Prize in 1960 JFK
became the Democratic nominee for the
presidency when he was just 43 years old
the public loved Jack Kennedy because he
seems like any other normal guy he spoke
with a Boston accent and he wasn't
afraid to visit the factories and shake
hands of the average American even
though he came from a wealthy family
people knew that the Kennedys were
self-made and sought that he was very
down-to-earth young voters of the 1960s
they were eager for change and he
represented the ideal American when he
moved to the White House in 1961 Jack
placed his younger brother Bobby as the
new Attorney General even though he was
only 35 years old the media was obsessed
with the Kennedys Jackie would appear in
magazines showing off her interior
design skills at the White House and a
French fashion was always front page
news what they didn't know is that
behind the scenes
she was his rock she would help him by
translating foreign books and documents
all through the night while also giving
him a place to call home outside of work
he loved spending time with his two
children John Jr and Carolyn French said
that the Oval Office was always filled
with the kids toys and the first thing
he did every morning was watch cartoons
and eat cereal with them despite having
such a beautiful young family JFK was
known for having not so secret affairs
rumors circulated that he was dating the
buxom movie star Marilyn Monroe and
phone records proved that she frequently
called the White House but for all of
his secret affairs Jackie never strayed
from a loyalty she knew about his
infidelity and considered getting a
divorce but chose to stay together for
the sake of Jack's political career in
later interviews Jackie said that Jack
never stopped appreciating the fact that
they were lucky enough to live in the
White House she described it as
constantly feeling like a kid on
Christmas because they were always
gushing over the history that surrounded
them they never took a moment for
granted the Kennedys youthful enthusiasm
is often credited for pushing America
through the space race since JFK helped
bring America to the moon Jack gave the
impression that he genuinely enjoyed his
job as president he was known for
smiling in the middle of a question from
a journalist because he'd already
thought of her would he come back he
treated his press conferences almost
like they were an audience for jokes
that he was writing in his spare time
one day he was holding a piece of paper
as if he was about to say something
incredibly serious to the crowd he then
looked up and said he smiles in the room
bust out in laughter
even though he was always smiling for
the press John F Kennedy was an expert
at hiding his pain he has been credited
for saving the United States from the
Cuban Missile Crisis and preventing
nuclear war during the Eisenhower
administration the CIA was planning to
invade Cuba to bring down the Communist
leader Fidel Castro when JFK was sworn
into office in January of 1961 he was
briefed on the plan that was already
underway this was the famous mission
known as the Bay of Pigs and
unfortunately it was an utter failure
after this Fidel Castro captian American
soldiers and threatened the United
States with the nuclear bombs after a
series of negotiations Kennedy agreed to
send 53 million dollars in baby food and
medication to Cuba in exchange for the
lives of the American prisoners by 1962
the threat of nuclear war had subsided
in a collection of interviews called the
Jackie Kennedy tapes we learned that it
was terrifying for the young couple to
enter office and immediately have such a
huge burden on their shoulders during
the Cuban Missile Crisis JFK was so
upset about the possibility of nuclear
war that he hardly slept and one day
simply bed into the next she also said
that they had a conversation about what
to do in the case of an attack
jacqueline was more than willing to die
with Jack she said that if there was not
enough time to get to the bunker she
would stand beside him on the White
House lawn to watch the world end Jack
Kennedy truly did care for the American
people and he loved them even if he
didn't know them personally his wife
Jackie said that he would often come
home sobbing whenever he heard any
tragic news of Americans dying he had
first-hand experience serving in World
War two so the last thing he wanted was
for the United States to get involved in
the Vietnam War
the media accused him of being soft on
communism but he was firm on his
decision if he was still alive to
complete a second term there is a very
real possibility that the 58,000 220
Americans who died in Vietnam would have
never met that fate but as we all know
lyndon b johnson declared war on vietnam
in 1964
on November the 22nd 1963 John F Kennedy
and his presidential motorcade was
driving through the streets of Dallas
Texas Jack was waving to the crowd and
sitting next to his wife Jackie in the
back of a 1961 Lincoln Continental the
governor of Texas John Connally and his
wife were sitting in front of them just
as they were passing the Texas School
Book Depository at least three shots
were fired jack was hit in the neck and
the next was a fatal head shot at least
one of the bullets or say at Connally
John F Kennedy he was pronounced dead
and vice president lyndon b johnson
assumed the role of presidents of the
united states the entire country was
stunned everyone who was alive back then
remembers exactly where they were when
Jack Kennedy was killed and the entire
nation mourned their president a man
named Abraham Zapruder was in the crowd
during the attack and he filmed the
parade with his 8 millimeter camera he
was not the only one filming that day
but he captured the clearest picture of
what actually happens once an engine
beat Johnson became the new presidents
he ordered an investigation known as the
Warren Commission to examine the facts
of the shooting including a
frame-by-frame analysis of the support
of film the head of the CIA Allen Dulles
was one of the men on the committee and
many believed that his influence
completely manipulated the results of
the investigation the Warren Commission
came to the conclusion that Lee Harvey
Oswald worked alone he was already under
investigation for collaborating with the
Soviet Union and for being a potential
terrorist he also worked at the Texas
School Book Depository which is where he
it set up his gun before he could be
questioned in court
Oswald was killed two days later by a
man named Jack Ruby the incident was
broadcast on live TV all of this seemed
to convenience and plenty of people
believed that there was a much larger
conspiracy at hand now there are a lot
of theories out there about who was
behind JFK's assassination so keep in
mind that we'll never have enough time
to go over all of them in this video one
of the many reasons why people find the
Warren Commission so hard to believe is
the fact that only three shell casings
were found that were fired by Lee Harvey
Oswald two out of three bullets were
shattered upon impact leaving tiny
fragments behind however there is one
bullet that supposedly traveled through
both John F Kennedy and Governor
Connolly's bodies and yet somehow it
remained completely intact this idea is
called the Magic Bullet theory and it's
obviously really hard
believe many people believe that there
were more than just three shots fired
and that was the second gunman they
believe this third bullet was planted in
the car afterwards by the CIA if there
was more than one shooter there is the
very real possibility that multiple
people were behind plotting his death
and the CIA wants us to believe that it
was just one crazy American hating
terrorists one of the only ways to prove
that the where other shots fired would
be if we saw the proof on video there
was supposedly a different angle films
of the shooting by a man called Orville
Nix which is called the grassy knoll
footage he sold one copy to the local
press for $5,000 and he gave the second
copy to the FBI in this film there is
supposedly evidence that there was a
second shooter hiding behind the bushes
in a grassy knoll however the government
seized the footage and Knicks claims
that when he was given it back there
were sections of the tape that had been
removed
Orvil Knicks his granddaughter Gale
Knicks Jackson sued the US government
for 10 million dollars or getting her
family's original film back but they
claimed to no longer have it in 2017 the
CIA Declassified thousands of records
about the JFK assassination that had
never been seen by the public while it
gives more insights into the case it
does little to fuel the fire of any
particular conspiracy theory we may
never know the whole story of what
happens during JFK's assassination then
if the truly was to cover up we have no
control over what's been done in the
past if he could see what happened to
his legacy surely jack would want us to
remember that he lived every day like it
was his last and when asked if he had
any regrets he only said I wish I had
more good times we'll leave you today
with the words of Jacqueline Kennedy
Jack was young and loved you know
everything jack was the most
unselfconscious person I had ever seen
he could naturally be attractive in a
crowd in a room it was like having so
many things in common with the many
sides of you everyone found a part of
themselves in a jack so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe it got
brand new videos just like this several
times per week so hit that subscribe
button so you find out about all of
those also feelings are something else
to watch right now why not click I'm on
the videos from the archives that are on
the screen right now and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]